Mayor Mitch Landrieu what's your
Democrats be doing in order to win in
the south oh good cause tell the truth
tell the truth it's important you know
you went when you don't have to go to
the far left you don't have to go to the
far right mayor's we solve problems and
I think people kind of look at Congress
and say how come you can't solve any
problems and that's what we do and
people are not as ideologically bent I
believe in the country as we seem to
think that they are and I just think you
got it you got to get things done
figure it out in a country run by all
women mayor that's true I'm for that but
we're gonna have a fight at a democratic
point like the Republicans are gonna
have about center-left right that's
gonna be a battle royal and it'll
prepare us for the future
all right Chris Hayes what do you say to
people that claim that MSNBC is the
liberal equivalent to Fox News I've
defended your network many times on that
point it makes me crazy and that you
won't because you know Fox News does not
stick to reality MSNBC's liberal-leaning
but they stick to reality but I'll let
you answer that question what do you say
to people and that your network only
focuses on Trump for profits so I'll
take the first the second the first
question which is that the way to
understand Fox News is it was built by a
very unique man named Roger Ailes know
who had a foot in two different worlds
he was a TV show business guy and he was
a politics guy this is a guy who advised
Richard Nixon he advised George HW Bush
what he was building and the owner of
that network Robert Rupert Murdoch was
explicitly a political project that was
the goal from the beginning it was he it
was an ideological project it was a
political project it was a media product
that has never been the case at MSNBC
never been the case there is no Roger
Ailes of MSNBC it was never believe me
it was not built by any Ailes like
figure it ended up being where it is in
primetime largely because he found an
audience for that right it was rich on
it yeah and it was a reflection of the
fact that by hook and by crook a market
demand was found which brings us the
second point that you focus on Trump for
ratings Donald Trump's president I
states and it turns out people really
want to hear about what the president I
States is doing
and there's only so much that you're
gonna apologize for covering the
president right and I know everybody's
ratings are up due to Donald Trump and
by the way he loves that and takes
credit for it right I mean he was Joe
it's his favorite thing did you see him
out he doesn't want anyone else to make
money on the fact that they're using his
image and and persona to make money he
wants to figure out how it can all come
to him did you see him in Pennsylvania
before the special election really did
the robot and he was saying you'd hate
it if I was boring as if the most
important thing is that the emperor toss
bread and circus to the boy
absolutely and in fact that's how he
picks people too apparently he likes
Bolton yes he's interesting as opposed
to McMaster who was more boring yeah all
right omona in 2003 you called liberals
useful idiots of the Russians would you
say it applies to Republicans and Trump
now the title of my book was useful
idiots I it was aids in the title art
okay it was the it was a quote from
Vladimir Lenin who said that you're the
girls in the West would be useful idiots
for us and we could tell them all kinds
of lies and they'd repeat them and you
know so that was what my point was I
think it's still valid and I think yes
it does apply to some Republicans today
and there are some there you know what I
just want to say this on behalf of the
Republican Party since I've been hard on
them tonight I do think that we can
either save this this great American
institution or we can turn the page and
I think we should save the Republican
Party
well we or maybe I keep saying go back
to Republican classic you know I think
they should
[Applause]
they need a Mitt Romney somebody who's
you know Mitt Romney's looking pretty
good now Gina are there any EPA
regulations that you would be in favor
of repealing that's a really good
question
yeah the ones about those garage door
openers and I don't love every
regulation you only regulate when you
feel like there's a need to do that when
somebody is harming somebody else and
you need to resolve a market failure yes
so yeah there are some that that should
go away and we look at them we are
required to look at them like every five
or eight years you look at them you make
changes you try to keep up to date but
what you don't do is go in with a list
of things that you want to get rid of
regardless of knowing anything about
them or looking at them and do it for
the sole purpose of reducing business
cost to certain constituencies that's
not what we could good answer
how old Trump's trade war destabilize US
Foreign Relations yeah and you know he
he kind of went back on the steel one
right and now and then he put one's on
it's just like a mean girl with the
shades the steel tariffs is a great
example of a very efficient means of
producing corruption which is to say I
know it's a black a blanket tariff but
I'll make someone on one side deals with
everybody like maybe you stay at the
Trump Hotel and maybe you hook up my
son-in-law with some financing I'm like
maybe we could work out it's like it
really is like a classic means of using
the state to produce corruption and now
we've got all these individual bilateral
deals they're going to carve it out
ultimately what it's going to end up
with is China's gonna sort of punch us
back right now we are not in a trade war
we're at the beginnings of something
that might be coming right now it's
actually fairly penny-ante but if it
gets worse it's gonna have a real real
concept I can't wait for the term voter
to walk into Walmart and there's nothing
there thank you everybody thank you
[Applause]